hi everyone I'm so this
I'm engineer idea we are building an
open-source self-service dinner platform
um alright let's get started so data
comes in all shapes sizes and formats
meaning you have complex data like JSON
which is very loosely based you have
where your sizes meaning you have
petabytes guilty that sometimes you just
have megabytes formats right so you have
like I mentioned JSON or CSV right so
these are generated by entities like us
or by sensors right and they could be a
stream being captured in storage systems
right so in your company you'll probably
have variety of these data storage
systems for example you probably store
your documents in MongoDB or your
transactions in sequel server or you
just wanna store files you properly
store them in our file system right
maybe just you ate a file system in a
few honest or not superior HDFS you
could even store data in elasticsearch
so it's easily indexable right so from
there you wanna look at how there gets
to your applications right it's like
your Python applications interpreter or
how how it gets to your VI tools like
tableau right
it seems dinner takes a very complex
path right for example it goes through a
lot of wrangling or curation right
it even has may go through a bunch of
ETL cycles so you say hey from this
system after more to this system just so
I can analyze it right so let's let's
look at how how such a flow would look
like so it's right say I'm analyzing the
young increase the font size right so
y'all published
and published a subset of their dataset
which shows which which is difficult of
what Yelp has right businesses reviews
and user data and I'm not happy with the
suggestions it has I'm I want to find
restaurants in Las Vegas that are most
reviewed and I want to actually use a
different metric like I want to use the
reviews that were useful to other people
who are looking at that review right so
for example the up could store their
business information in elasticsearch
because you search for that right it
could store the reviewed the review data
in in something like MongoDB because
MongoDB provides a flexible schema and
you can have fields dropped once a while
or some fields missing and all of that
right you can add new fields things like
that so how would how would you how do
you answer this question right so this
is absurd what you put on your book for
simplicity all right so first let's
algorithmic it would work by saying hey
let me first find the best restaurants
among the best restaurants right so
first I need to find the best
restaurants in LA and Las Vegas sorry
and then based on and then I need to do
some analysis and I need to do some
analysis to find what some useful
reviews are and then do a join across
those two and then find out what what
the best numbers come out to be all
right so first I write some I import to
interact with elasticsearch it's it's
running on a certain host somewhere and
then I'm searching what elasticsearch is
the concept of indexes which is
basically a bunch of documents together
right and then I'm looking at business
data in that right and I'm interested in
certain set of fields in there and I
want to see I want to filter them by Las
Vegas right and I'm saying that anything
greater than any restaurant that has a
review count greater than 100 right you
put out other filters saying hey it has
really high ratings but for simplicity
let's just reduce
and then I have to normalize it
I have to normalize it so I can fit it
in to a data frame right all right
here's what a sample data looks like it
has a business idea categories city name
review found accessible right and how
many stars it has all right now that
I've found out what businesses there are
in Las Vegas I need to find out what
reviews they're right what people have
review for this I'm using a [ __ ] module
by would you be and anything that is
that other users found useful as a
metric for that right so and I'm doing
it in batches cuz I'll explain that
later right a sample of that looks like
hey this this user ID reviewed this
business and this is what they think and
actually quite a few users for it useful
all right so now that I have these two
data sets I need to I need to do a joint
across them to figure out which
businesses were actually good enough for
these reviewers right so so one of the
key things is if you did this completely
in memory it actually breaks down it
doesn't even finish sometimes it just
says throws out memory blah blah right
so I had to do it in batches right I'm
gonna load MongoDB data in batches so
and if this is basically not so decent
code that basically iterates over
iterates over MongoDB cursor and it
returns data in batches right and I
picked 25 seemed reasonable
and what this also does is since I said
the bat size 225 here and I said the
iteration size to 25 at every for every
25 records to actually gonna make a
request and continue the cursor right
that's what this is doing
and now now let's do the actual joint
right the joint is between the business
data right on that on that table we saw
business ID on in this table we also saw
business a key and in order to an inner
join in
just ignore it's a type of joint all
right so now we found the results
meaning maybe we need to match the
business IDs in these reviews that are
there are streaming in in a way and
we're gonna match that against the
businesses that we have in memory right
so we are gonna do it
and Ursulines merge function that does
the joint for us and then we're gonna
append the results to it just gonna keep
track of all the matching ones right and
even this actually took a really long
time so I just took a very small number
so once I hit a certain limit for how
large my result set gets I just stop I
mean this is mainly big actually let it
run for a long time but it was too slow
and we'll discuss why that was too slow
so something like this will show up
meaning you have this restaurant for
example as for this evaluation of the
how good it is it has an average score
of average rating of five right so sorry
I forgot to mention I'm getting the
stars from the reviews which we found
useful right so I need to do a sum of
them that's what this is doing all right
so what is what are some things that I
did here so I wrote domain specific code
for elasticsearch our domain specific
code for [ __ ] and there's a few things
here they're actually happening right
turns out here right just join this for
example when I'm trying to get in to
transform the results from whatever what
the join return to something that I
wanna keep in memory this is actually
creating two copies turns out internally
and every time you append it also does
one more copy so but there's no reason
to actually copy the data right you can
just you know what the fields are you
have it in memory why make another copy
and every time I actually have to go
over the cursor right what I'm creating
is something like this right I need to
turn that
said that I'm getting from [ __ ] into a
list and then I need to turn it into a
date of it now that's again two more
copies right so an ideal an ideal
scenario would be that once the data is
read from a source system it's in a
format that that helps helps analytics
right in the sense that you don't have
to
once it's transformed from once it's
transferred from one system to another
you actually don't need to create a copy
what that and that's that's what I'm
going to talk about next so let's first
talk about how the layout is so you can
imagine a table three columns that way
and if you had laid it out in memory in
Graham for example typically you would
see them record after record right so
you will see the first field at the
first row and the second field of the
first row and so on you would see that
in order the problem with this is the
type of workload that that analytics
have they pick a few columns and the
work on them right they don't work on
the entire record per se right say
you're filtering on a certain column or
in your summing on another call you only
need those two columns right so
something like this would be a little
more useful because you will avoid cat
and cache misses right you will have say
for example you're picking the session
ID column right once you hit the first
one says let's still let's just look at
it as an integer and you want to do a
summer one right well if you hit the
first one and the next one is right
there right you don't have to reload
another record into memory for that so
let's let's base it off on that and
there's an open source project called
Apache ro that works to enable enable of
columnar analytics and what the goals of
our are simple so it enables columnar
in-memory analytics specifically meaning
once you have a DeLorean to a processes
memory you do not have you need to since
we've done representing the columnar
format that's that's very friendly to
analytical applications
and zero copy messaging what that means
is say you have you have two processes
running on the same node right so they
don't actually have if both represent
the underlying data in the same format
they don't actually have to send from
one system to another when you're
sending you're gonna serialize it when
you're receiving you're gonna be
serialize it and then you're gonna
convert it into the system's internal
representation right so all of those
steps that can be skipped for example by
using a memory map file right you can
just say hey look at this file and this
process also gonna look at the same file
since both of them had initially agreed
that this the form is the memory layout
they're gonna deal with then they don't
have to do any copies right
and you can also have inter process
communication meaning you across a
network right meaning process on one
node is trying to talk to cross on
another node what you would do is
negotiate a schema for the memory layer
that you're gonna have and then you're
gonna send it over you're gonna you want
to send that what the layout looks like
and then you're gonna send the data
along and the other system once it reads
it off the socket doesn't actually need
to create another copy right because
they already know what the layout Nosler
so this this obviously requires things
to work across languages and so we have
multiple implementations in C++ Java and
their bindings in other languages too
and definitely like more like there's
more is complex and so there needs to be
support for nested schema so we based
it's based off on the JSON model just so
we support not abilities we support or
their support for arrays the support for
objects right so that's the goals of
arrow and so what system communication
across across all the services you have
in your company would be instead of
copying and converting between any two
systems it would just be hey we all
speak the same language internally and
externally so we can just agree on every
on how the radar looks
so another key thing for this is
adoption you need a lot of projects to
do expose such an API so there's not a
lot of copies right so how does this
actually help let's go back to the phone
right looking at the current way so that
means if you had that right this call
right would not be if the batch cursor
API in [ __ ] for example was speaking
arrow then this call would basically not
incur any costs right you're not copying
any data you're just looking at the data
through this frame right and then this
cost right the cost of this maybe the
maybe you can maintain a memory layout
that just is pointers to the records in
one data frame and and so here to write
when you're you don't you're not
creating any copies you're actually just
saying hey I'm only interested in these
two fields so it's like a projection I
don't I ignore the other fields that are
in there in the data frame and I just
look at these two alright so we have up
to now we have so we have a common
language to speak but we don't have you
don't have something that interacts with
multiple systems right so the initial
thing that we had was something that was
the program was interacting with MongoDB
analyst elasticsearch I was coming up
with some answers so how do you do that
is what remya tries to solve we're a
self-service data platform and we are
open source self-service data platform
again into the details when I'm doing
the demo and we are also built on other
open source technologies like calcite we
use calcite extensively planning we use
we use arrow extends would be and in our
execution engine and I have a lot of
stickers
we are thingy is in our are that and you
can get some of those have arrow
stickers as well all right I imagine
what the problem we are trying to solve
in a picture is this you have a bunch of
data sources
and you have a bunch of applications and
you want you want to provide a unified
access layer to those applications as if
these systems are just won right
so that's that's what that's what we try
to do and one of the key things to that
is search right you want to be able to
search the data sources data sets that
you have in your company you want to be
able to curate them meaning you want to
drop some fields or you want to massage
the data somehow that's what curation
helps you right at the end of this year
if you're not happy we have a we have an
intelligent cache layer which which is
how we accelerate data right and the
thing about virtualization is in the
original description I had was basically
when you have data movement from one
system to another it's typically two to
help make it a more I guess it helps the
applications understand the data more
right so you're making the raw data
you're cleaning it up and then you're
making it into in a form that's that's
more digestible by applications but you
don't actually you don't really do that
what you're doing is actually going on a
lens right you're saying hey I'm looking
at the raw data but then I let me let me
wear all this lens and say hey this
field is actually a time stamp even
though it looks like a string right
you're just interpreting it as a time
stamp so you have this view of data
that's not really that's not really
changing the original rewrite itself
right what that helps with is you don't
have to make copies of the day right so
you're not gonna move from one system to
another you're just gonna say let me
interpret the data this way
that's what virtualization is and we
provide that across across different
alright I'll show you how similar thing
would work wait yeah so we support let
me just make sure things are all right
so you have the for example elastic we
support HP's HDFS people know what that
is and we have [ __ ] data so for example
elastic has a concept of index right so
yeah
index this is a simple browser interface
that we have and Yelp is an index and
these are the data sets that these are
the cases that I have in the Yelp index
right these are the types
that's what elasticsearch and [ __ ] I
have it the same database called Yelp
and I have different collections right
in each collection is basically a bunch
of documents right that's for example
look at user collection supposedly users
can be funny too I thought only reviews
alright so this one right this one shows
a tabular representation of that alright
let's get to what we're trying to solve
first we were looking at elastic data
set right we were saying let's go to the
business data and alright so first I'm
filtering based on the city so I have a
sick let me pick I'm only keeping I'm
only interested in Las Vegas so let me
apply that right let me apply that
filter so what you're actually seeing in
the sample of the data for now because
it's a it's a large data set we don't
show you the entire data set at once
when but when you run it so this is a
preview of the data set but when you run
it you can hit run we'll do that a
little bit all right so we went to the
last fingers restaurants and then we
have review count greater than 100
where's the review found the format
sometimes changes so have to be oh right
here
I'm gonna keep only the ones that are
greater than so I can just say hundred
so now I'm looking at I'm not actually
modifying I'm not transferring any data
from MongoDB into premiere I'm just
saying hey let's only look at this data
set this this view on the data set right
I'm not actually interested in any other
attributes let me just drop a few I know
all the state is always gonna be nevada
name okay
underneath it's actually just a sequel
statement because we're just gonna say
our city is Las Vegas yeah so if you
found it so answer all right I'm gonna
save this as Vegas so now what actually
created is is called a virtual data set
right so we had the physical data set
and we have a view of that asset and
that's captured here all right and then
what did I do
I did a join and then I imported the
right and then I imported the [ __ ]
[ __ ] DB data based on the useful count
greater than being fine right so let's
go there now now I have reviews right
notice that useful is actually part of a
nested field right it's a JSON blob so
that's what this tiny little thing is
showing that it's complex so I'm looking
at useful right I can extract that field
right and I'm interested in useful words
now and I want the useful words to be
greater than a 5 so I can again keep
only the ones
there are five
I see not interested in the entire text
so I'll just drop this this is probably
the largest one all right
let's say let's say this one has
okay so we have two virtual data sets
right and we can now apply the same
joint algorithm right which is to say
let's look at restaurants and let's do a
group i right sorry it's not as good bad
and so I'm gonna join so notice how it
actually tries to suggest some other
data sets that are will as potential
joint exists but it's a custom job
because I'm only interested in my
reviews okay so here then I have to pick
which what's the key that I'm joining on
business ID on this side and this side I
have business ID as well and then just
keeping the other columns alright let's
go back again we see that now we did a
join and then we have to only pick the
source name and stars right and we have
source name which i think is called
named stars the stars actually is the is
the stars on the review sorry on the
business side and this one is the one
that user had so stars again now this I
can save again as a joint data set right
all right
so John later said I can drop most of
the fields right if I want I can edit
the original sequel I don't have to look
at I don't have to always do it visually
if I understand sequel then I might as
well to sequel all right so there's user
stars and so we have a search in there
all right I need to give user stars and
business name
all right I'm just dropping the other
console
right
all right so we did the same same
algorithm through this except I don't
think either 2pi right
meaning I need to collapse all the ones
that work for a specific restaurant so
let's do a group by measure I'm gonna do
a sum on the user stars
average
this to be bit similar to what the
original one load
all right
can you preview and I will say similar
result right so join us if I go back now
to where I created these these are there
is a decorator
I created a similar flow now how do I
get it back to two pandas right so now
that I created
usually curated the data and created
this the same algorithm through drags
and drops and sequel that's what it
looks like so to this we need PI ODBC
which is a what do we see connect which
helps it which is a module that helps
you use they already see API to connect
to databases and Ramiro has a VC API
right so we are connecting through an
open-source driver and actually this is
wrong so I need to fix that too from
each dot
all right
so I set up my initialization file home
directory to point to that cluster and
to the setup with my credentials let's
require for any ODBC application
typically all right so running this oops
we're a mess
driver did not supply never right very
useful okay I'm guessing it's with some
tax no okay so let's see maybe the job
field let me find out what happened to
the job
Oh Phil you're parsing very although all
right let's look at what the error or it
doesn't like foots that's where it is
right this driver doesn't always give us
nice error messages now it's running so
there because the results so maybe we
got different numbers but that's because
the other one I restricted to a certain
dataset size right okay so few things
that this algorithm did that was that
were nice was the fact that we only we
already filtered the results from
MongoDB and we already filter the
results from elasticsearch before
loading into our system what that means
is we have instead of loading the entire
dataset into pandas which is ridiculous
on elasticsearch and [ __ ] instead of
doing that we said hey do this part of
the filtering in your system and then
return the results right so that's very
important and we actually do that do
that that avoids data movement right
unnecessary data movement that's what we
do - Remi oh so when we when we ran this
query they actually did not it did not
scan the entire tables from
elasticsearch or MongoDB into tremie oh
and then do the join what it did is
again it's it's smart enough to figure
out that parts of parts of the query
okay it's defined in the other data sets
right for example in this one it says
hey this is this where condition can
actually be pushed to MongoDB and that's
very important because that will reduce
the data set size that's coming into
drummy similarly that's that's true for
plastic surgery as well when you look at
this these two are conditions that can
be pushed to elastic selection right so
we don't have to scan scan the data or
move it across systems all right we have
is when you're looking at the joint data
sets you can also see where the data
came from we know that was an elastic
search and MongoDB and then we had this
view of the data and then we on in a
string so to add a view of the date on
MongoDB
and then we didn't join in our in our
system right
how am i doing so yeah that's that's
Crimea we have we be right here that
lives between applications and resources
and this allows you to access any scale
data or any type of data from your from
your Python right and it's an open
source as I mentioned it's an open
source project and you're welcome to
contribute a results an open source
project you can see a lot more tutorials
on how the internals of Crimea are these
are our tutorials on how to use it
through pandas or have no for example on
our website yeah questions yeah
good question you caught me there I
forgot to mention where's one part
that's missing there we are using an
ODBC API which is a standard API which
does not support which does not support
aro right as a as an API so we are
working on that so we are working on
providing another API so actually what
happens is it comes all the way to the
client in term in in those arrow batches
but at the end it gets translated to an
ODBC api and then into a data frame so
instead of that you could just collapse
those conversions and copies and you
could just provided a aro API right
that's very important again right
because you can avoid the copy there and
right as of now you're expecting the
data set sizes to be small that should
be fine because it's only when you're
doing moving large amounts of data that
error really helps yeah
right so in this case we are always so
what I did not what I showed was that
the data was directly coming from the
sources there was no copy maintained in
grêmio right of any form what you could
do is if you are if there are some
popular data sets virtual or physical
you can accelerate it meaning you can
say hey catch this data in your system
we allow for that and how we allow
updates in that is we it's almost
transparent to the user you define a
policy on how how fresh the data should
be right you say maybe three minutes or
three hours is how much I'm willing to
give a leeway for so we do have you can
set those policies and accelerations
that's right
um across on the same on different nodes
that's right for if it's on different
nodes then you do have to send it over
the wire but then you're only send and
within the there's no civilization or D
civilization cause or there's no copy
you didn't do a format that that process
understands if you're using something
like arrow that's correct so you're if
you're unless you're using shared memory
that's right you're not but in this case
there's no reason not to use shared
memory if you're gonna actually share
with another process some a format that
the other process already understands
that is correct
[Applause]